in the previous session we saw the graph
of the function f of X is equal to x
squared it was a curve like this a
parabola we just substitute the
different values in place of X got
respective values for Y and plotted the
points to get this graph it touches the
x-axis at the origin that's because when
we substitute a 0 in place of X we get
the value of y or the function as 0
let's try making a few changes to this
function we change the function to f of
X is equal to x squared plus 1 make an
attempt to draw an approximate graph of
this function when x is 0 Y will be
equal to 1 0 comma 1 will be one of the
points on its graph if you try out more
values you get a parabola like this
interesting now try drawing the
approximate graph of this function when
x is 0 Y will equal 0 minus 1 which is
minus 1 0 comma minus 1 will be the
point the parabola will look a bit like
this what is the point of all this all
the functions you see here are quadratic
the degree is 2 the graphs are not
straight lines because the equations are
not linear what is the general form of a
quadratic function f of X equal to ax
squared plus BX plus C that's the
general form where a B and C can take
numerical values do you remember how we
had calculated the roots of a quadratic
equation the roots will be the value of
x for which the function will equal 0
yes the roots are minus B plus minus
root of b squared minus 4ac over 2a
ending on the values of a B and C we get
the roots of the equation to know how
many roots an equation has just this
value is enough if positive then two
roots if zero then one root and if
negative then no roots look at these
functions they're all quadratic with B
equal to zero so let's see what B
squared minus 4ac tells us in each case
in the first function a is 1 B is 0 and
C as well is 0 this will equal 0 it
means we have just one root here and
guess what the function graph also tells
us that it has one root root is nothing
but the value of x as Y is 0 here at
this point the value of the function is
0 just one root let's move on to the
second function B is 0 and a and C are
one each this will equal minus 4
negative value of this means no roots
thus the graph also stay the same at
what value of x is the function equal to
0 look closely there is no such value of
x at which the function is 0 it has no
roots the third function is interesting
B is 0 a is 1 and C is minus 1 this
value equals 4 this is positive and
hence it should have two roots does the
graph say that absolutely the value of f
of X is 0 at these two points they are
the two roots of the equation remember
to know how many roots an equation has
we just need to look at the value of b
squared minus 4ac 0 then 1 root positive
then 2 roots and negative then no roots
quadratic functions is the favorite
topic of the paper setters you really
need to understand them were y is equal
to x squared how does the graph look
like this so we know this well what
about y equal to minus x squared how
will its graph look simple it will look
like this if it's the negative of a
function we just invert it to see how we
get this just try substituting different
values in place of X okay good how do we
draw the graph of y equal to 10x squared
it will look something like this you see
that when we multiplied x squared by 10
the functions graph narrowed be patient
we're getting to the point the next
function is y is equal to minus 10x
squared the minus will just invert the
function it will look like this
let's summarize all that we saw if a is
positive by a I mean the coefficient of
x squared if a is positive the graph
always opens upwards as in these two
cases where a is positive and if a is
negative then the graph will open
downwards as in these two cases there's
another thing we can derive looking at
these graphs when the absolute value of
a increases the curve gets narrower one
became 10 and we saw that the curve got
narrower and we can say that if the
absolute value of a reduces then the
curve will get wider 10 to 1 and the
curve got wider so no matter what
quadratic function you face you should
easily be able to draw or interpret its
graph
you